[Music]
whenever you email canvas at Yale it's
usually the one of the two of us so we
do have faces this is what we look like
we're always smiling when we hear the
complaints so it's great so we're
actually talking about the upcoming
external apps in canvas and one of the
things we did want to talk about is what
exactly is an external app so an
external app is a third-party
application that can be embedded and
integrated with it within canvas
seamlessly we actually heard about one
Piazza is actually a third-party app so
a lot of the tools that you use the sign
up tool and a couple the other ones that
we were listening to are consider
third-party apps they actually are
really great for if you want to have a
something in your class that canvas
doesn't quite do there's an app for that
so it's great I also want to kind of
talk about the process of requesting
external apps there's a lot of
technology out there that can help your
teaching and we know that it can be
almost overwhelming to look at all the
technology available to you so there is
an app external app request form that
you can fill out saying hey I heard
about this technology I think will be
beneficial can we integrate it so that
is step one and we do have deadlines so
fall you would have to request the
external app by March 1st spring is
October 1st and summer is December 1st
so once the request for the external app
is created we then at the Center for
teaching and learning we get a demo of
the app after we say after the demo we
say hey this is really great tool I
think it could benefit a lot of people
at Yale we then go it goes through a
wonderful process where it's the OGC
register i TS of betting this step in
the process can take between weeks and
months of the process time so that's why
we have the deadline so far in advance
because it has to be ensured that we're
protecting the student data and the
student information because that's very
important to us
as you whole and to us you use at the
technology once it goes through that
lovely process it actually then gets the
approval for the integration and then it
gets integrated so the canvas team will
then integrate it into the courses we
then have a pilot which can run about
one to two semesters to paint on the
pilot it could be one course it could be
an entire department or it could be
university-wide and then we also have a
post pilot analysis so that's what
worked what didn't work was this tool
successful so this is the essentially
entire process the external apps it's
really fun so then especially that
vetting part so the non integrated
external app use so say for example you
found it you found a tool that you want
to use in your class but you don't
really want to incorporate it or
integrate it in canvas you just want to
try it out first well with that in mind
we do want to be very cognizant of what
student data is going to be out there
so we are going to be working you can
come to us and say hey I want to use
this app can you please make sure help
me make sure that my students
information is not going to be sold on
by Facebook or anything like that so you
can actually work with us to ensure that
the data protection the data is going to
be protected and what student
information is going to be passed so
that's the fun part and you can always
email canvas at Yale that edu for any
questions about this we have been
learning a lot about this process and a
lot of tools that you guys have been
wanting to integrate so a lot of the
tools before we talk about the upcoming
ones I do want to give an example that
say for example Piazza was a tool that a
lot of faculty were using what was not
incorporated within or incorporated
within canvas we went through this whole
process and that's and how it's now it's
the stream Louis integration so here's
Cristie thank you
am i on yeah all right so with that on
the Piazza note I will jump to one of
the last bullet points in my first slide
which is poll everywhere
which is
going to be integrated into canvas so
I'll start by saying that just since
we're on that topic so one of the other
ones is voicethread a lot of the
language courses have already been using
it and that's why we decided to pilot it
and see if it's something that we should
integrate if so many people are already
using it so voicethread is basically
their catch line transforming media into
collaborative spaces with video voice
and text commenting so I'll go over what
this looks like and then play pause it
is a new one that we had the need to do
quiz types in videos so interactive quiz
in videos essentially and then pull
everywhere so many of you may have
already been using it but now with the
help of Brian's team we're integrating
in it into canvas so I will start with
voicethread so it's a web-based platform
that enables teachers and students to
upload video documents voice commenting
and basically you can think of it as a
highly interactive discussion space so
we first started thinking about it
because we had complaints about the
discussion tool they wanted people
wanted to be able to do more with it so
that's when we started looking into
voicethread so the glue pen feels like a
slideshow I'll give you examples and
what's neat is that after media is added
so let's say Jen added some media to a
slides me as a teacher or a student
could go in and comment on any of that
content that she put in and what's nice
is that the integration with all of
these that we just will mention is that
you can use it like in assignments and
it just goes right into the gradebook so
what does this look like and I'm just
going to do three quick slides for the
sake of time and overarching click the
Create button add media so in this case
I think I added an image file so I have
these different things I can choose to
pick from what I want to add and I just
grabbed a photo from my computer and the
first photo
came up yeah this screenshot that I took
but I put this here because you can add
a couple of different media types so
maybe I wanted to start with an image
and then go into a video and then end
with of some voice comment so to show
you what it looks like if I put it as an
assignment I called this out of make a
comment that was the assignment and Jen
luckily your pictures small enough I
didn't want you to kill me but I put you
up there you can see that Tonya tester
which is Jen's account made a comment at
this point in this image and she also
along with me watching her make that
comment in the voicethread circle the
dog's face and she was talking about it
so that's briefly what that looks like
the next one is play pause it and I
found this on their Twitter play videos
posit questions so I guess that's why
they named it that I'm and again this is
like the interactive quizzing feature so
I will jump to that um what's nice is
that let's say that I upload a
three-minute film clip I can pause it at
any time so maybe the first minute and
say reflect on the last on the first
minute of that video and they could
submit a discussion question or some
sort of comment these are the different
types of things they can add multiple
choice for your response a couple of
others I'm gonna go past it here because
I have an image of it and again the
integration allows you to align this
with a gradebook in canvas so what does
this look like all right
so let's pretend I went past the canvas
stuff I'm right in play pause it
first thing upload your content from
where so this is truly video and so
let's say that I had it in Vimeo I just
paste the link there up at the top and
the next thing I see is the actual video
so whenever I click on this these dots I
get all of these options on what do I
want to add right there so maybe I made
a syllabus video and in it is
I was like why did I just say that and
then you know as a joke and so if people
aren't paying attention you know it
really catches them and you can't go
past the video until you answer the
certain questions or click on a URL or
there's reflective pauses but these are
the different kinds of things you can
add to that and yep just a little bit
bigger in case you couldn't see that and
so what does this look like in a video
what does a question look like is so I
was just saying something and I said in
this video the presenter will show you
how to it so it's fill in the blank so
they could write in their answer and
click continue and then right away you
can choose so that it gives them
immediate feedback in this case I got
the question wrong but I am able to see
the correct answer and then I can
continue on yep there's just another
picture of it so already available in
canvas in case you're curious we have
this available on our help canvas don't
yell dot edu and you probably a lot of
you already use ares its course reserves
you may not even know it faculty enlight
connects you to the bookstore mob lab
som was using for gaming Piazza we heard
about perusal and all Spurs all allows
you to do annotation and then Panopto is
our media library software so I'll just
click on that link just because and
here's our external apps overview for
the entire list of everything we're
doing so you can see what we're piloting
what's already been approved what's been
requested so yeah questions
so the question was to embed from
YouTube into play pause it can you just
paste the link the answer is yes so I'm
a little hesitant to ask but uh so you
were talking a little bit about external
apps sources internal apps it would be
integrated external apps and then non
integrate external apps I actually have
a very specific question about padam tow
so we integrate a lot of our videos into
our curriculum ok opto through Panopto
but we can't just have them download
canvas
correct they have to have Panopto let's
say they have an ipod mm-hmm or an iPad
or a phone they have to have both apps
downloaded correct Brian how people use
they should I mean they should play back
in a browser is that sorry is that what
the question yeah I guess I guess I just
they don't need to go to another app it
doesn't have to be on their device no
all right
if you've ever been on a consultation
with me as soon as videos comes up I go
Brian
does anybody have any other L questions
Oh with the poll everywhere that's
coming or yeah I know right now you can
use like our phones and think having
think web-enabled in order to pull in is
that still gonna be a possibility or do
they have to get a library device Oh
John got how's it okay
I suppose everywhere will actually be
exclusively either browser based or an
app on a phone or a tablet so there
won't be a physical device that I'll
check out regards to the video are you
guys gonna have any plugins for closed
captioning and things that are gonna
take place
I believe that campus uses Amara and
Panopto you can add them in and Panopto
z' Panopto land but um so through the
editor and Panopto you can add captions
I'm actually all videos there's an
automatic captioning procedure which is
not accurate you would still need to go
back and correct them but you're able to
import those and then correct them if
you'd like John might have more to say
about that and the excellent help
article that Bryan put together on the
on the help pages that you can find in
the canvas help pages section Bryan
should have been a third person but
leave them microphone was Bryan cuz dad
yeah I think it might be straightforward
but I just don't I'm not sure I
understand what would be the benefits of
using polleverywhere through canvas
versus how we do it now which is either
as part of a PowerPoint or you know just
online so poll everywhere I mean it it's
function somewhat similarly you
integrated the canvas you can upload
responses to gradebook you can still do
do it through PowerPoint it just we're
piling it to see if it's be a better
smoother application than turning-point
which is what we currently support so it
might just be a little easier to use it
has the benefit being everything stored
in the cloud so you don't have to have
like your presentation or carry all that
information with you or you make sure
you're uploading the grades back to
canvas they can do all that
automatically any more questions for
Brian awesome thank you well thank you
so much we really appreciate your coming
to the lightning talks and again thank
you to everyone who helped make today
happen and if you have any feedback if
you're if you have any questions at all
please feel free to reach us at canvas
at yale.edu
and one of our team will get back to you
and and we look forward to doing this
again next year so we've if you think
about it and find something we've
totally want you to present next year so
next year we hope you'll come back oh
yes and there are remaining refreshments
and cookies and things please help
yourself thank you
[Music]